mike donovan's rebounds the miss  [Music]  bogey fires a three oh my goodness  unreal we don't want to put too much  pressure on it once you reach the  playoffs  none of that matters other than home  court advantage so you start off  oh no  [Applause]  shot clock resets at 14 jokic swiping at  boy on he'll try the baseline  wrap around oh what a shot shot of the  night for a nice slam  stolen clarkson took it away from the  joker  [Applause]  clarkson in the paint scoops it out  bogey three splash  mach career night against denver  and then bogey bogey siding  knocking it down jazz on the roll bogey  looking good donovich trying to add to  his career night  they're chanting his name at vivint  arena  the bounce the free throw 47.  [Applause]  blowing on that right hand don't cool it  off too much  48 most points by a jazz man since the  mailman  carl malone he scored 56  back on april 7th of 98 and another  takeaway  the jazz simply just took the heart out  of the